to improve the experience please turn
down the lights put on a pair of
headphones and enjoy the rake during the
summer of 2003 events in the
northeastern United States involving a
strange human-like creature sparked
brief local media interest before an
apparent blackout was enacted little or
no information was left intact as most
online in written accounts of the
creature were mysteriously destroyed
primarily focused in rural New York
State self-proclaimed witnesses told
stories of their encounters with a
creature of unknown origin emotions
ranged from extremely traumatic levels
of fright and discomfort to an almost
childlike sense of playfulness and
curiosity while their published versions
are no longer on record the memories
remained powerful several of the
involved parties began looking for
answers that year in early 2006 the
collaboration had accumulated nearly two
dozen documents dating between the 12th
century and present-day spanning four
continents in almost all cases the
stories were identical I've been in
contact with a member of this group and
was able to get some excerpts from their
upcoming book a suicide note
1964 as I prepare to take my life I feel
it necessary to assuage any guilt or
pain I have introduced through this act
it is not the fault of anyone other than
him for once I awoke and felt his
presence and I awoke and saw his form
once again I awoke and heard his voice
and looked into his eyes
cannot sleep without fear of what I my
next awake to experience I cannot ever
awake goodbye found in the same wooden
box with two empty envelopes addressed
to William and rose and one loose
personal letter with no envelope
dearest Linney I have prayed for you
he spoke your name a journal entry
translated from Spanish 1880 I have
experienced the greatest fear I have
experienced the greatest fear I have
experienced the greatest fear I see his
eyes when I close mine they are hollow
black they saw me and pierced me his wet
hand I will not sleep his voice a
Mariners log 1691 he came to me in my
sleep from the foot of my bed I felt a
sensation he took everything we must
return to England
we shall not return here again at the
request of the rake from a witness 2006
three years ago I had just returned from
a trip to Niagara Falls with my family
for the fourth of July we were all very
exhausted after a long day of driving so
my husband and I put the kids right to
bed and called me tonight at about 4:00
a.m. I woke up thinking my husband had
gotten up to use the restroom
I used the moment to steal back the
sheets only to wake him in the process I
apologized and told them that I thought
he got out of bed when he turned to face
me he gasped and pulled his feet up from
the end of the bed so quickly his knee
almost knocked me out of bed he then
grabbed me and said nothing after
adjusting to the dark for a half second
I was able to see what caused the
strange reaction
at the foot of the bed sitting and
facing away from us there was what
appeared to be a naked man or a large
hairless dog of some sort it's body
position was disturbing and unnatural as
if it had been hit by a car for some
reason I was not instantly frightened by
it but more concerned as to its
condition at this point I was someone
under the assumption that we were
supposed to help him my husband was
peering over his arm and knee tucked
into the fetal position occasionally
glancing had be before returning to the
creature in a flurry of motion the
creature scrambled to the side of the
bed and then crawled quickly in a sort
of flailing motion right along the bed
until it was less than a foot from my
husband's face the creature was
completely silent for about thirty
seconds just looking at my husband the
creature then placed its hand on his
knee and ran into the hallway leading to
the kid's room I screamed and ran for
the light switch planning to stop him
before he heard my children when I got
to the hallway the light from the
bedroom was enough to see it crouching
and hunched over about thirty feet away
he turned around and looked directly at
me covered in blood I flipped the switch
on the wall and saw my daughter Clara
the creature ran down the stairs while
my husband and I rushed to help our
daughter she was very badly injured and
spoke only once more in her short life
she said he is the rake my husband drove
his car into a lake that night while
rushing our daughter to the hospital he
did not survive
being a small town news got around
pretty quickly
the police were helpful at first and the
local newspaper took a lot of interest
as well however the story was never
published and the local television news
never followed up either for several
months my son Justin and I stayed in a
hotel near my parents house after we
decided to return home I began looking
for answers myself I eventually located
a man in the next town over who had a
similar story we got in contact and
began talking about our experiences he
knew of two other people in New York who
had seen the creature we now refer to as
the rake it took the four of us about
two solid years of hunting on the
Internet and writing letters to come up
with a small collection of what we
believe to be the accounts of the rake
none of them gave any details history or
follow up one journal had an entry
involving the creature in its first
three pages and never mentioned it again
a ship's log explained nothing of the
encounter saying only that they were
told to leave by the rake that was the
last entry in the log there were however
many instances where the creatures visit
was one of a series of visits with the
same person multiple people also
mentioned being spoken to my daughter
included this led us to wonder if the
rake had visited any of us before our
last encounter I set up a digital
recorder near my bed and left it running
all night every night for two weeks
I would tediously scan through the
sounds of me rolling around in bed each
day when I woke up by the end of the
second week I was quite accustomed to
the occasional sound of sleep while
blurring through the recording at eight
times the normal speed on the first day
of the third week I thought I heard
something different what I found was a
shrill voice it was the rake I can't
listen to it long enough to even begin
to transcribe it I haven't let anyone
listen to it yet why no he said I've
heard it before and I now believe that
it spoke when it was sitting in front of
my husband I don't remember hearing
anything at the time but for some reason
the voice on the recorder immediately
brings me back to that moment the
thoughts they must have gone through my
daughter's head make me very upset I
have not seen the rake since he ruined
my life
but I know that he has been in my room
while I slept I know and fear that one
night I'll wake up to see him staring at
me again